let's see who else wants to check in
today why don't we go to our caller from
the 727 area code who's calling today
from 7:00 to 7:00 7:00 to 7:00 we can
hear you we're on yeah we're not on
speaker are we we're not on speaker
we're on speaker gotcha nah not anymore
all right what can I do for you today
[Music]
it's really real that's what I'm doing
right I am like oh wait okay stop
Mobe all the time to be raised in the
world smoke it all up because it's crazy
dude right how do you doing good good
how are you family you well are you
talking to mirrors there another
conversation happening in the background
there are you high right now yeah gotcha
gotcha
all right well listen it's it's really
been a pleasure I so appreciate the
phone call it finally happened okay yeah
man I love you sure I'm glad I
discovered who you are in your program I
think you're awesome and you are
definitely in my daily routine now
thank you ever I'm polish crap is over
you know i so apprec questioning i love
you show me I think you're totally
awesome right on dude my PB even tell
you answered the real reason Trump won't
wear math right that was a good segment
that was a good segment all right
my friend thank you so much for the call
I am gonna let you go we are we are at a
time and Wow
today's calls I'm sweating my friends I
am sweating let's go to a break we will
take calls again sorry that I was not
able to get to everyone today